[Musique]
depuis le début de la crise les élus de
proximité comme les moeurs des 24
communes de l'île sont extrêmement
sollicités
raison pour laquelle le département
partenaire naturel des municipalités a
accueilli l'association des moeurs et
c'est important parce que c'est vrai que
l'audioconférence est une chose mais
c'est un aussi importante on se voit et
que l'on puisse discuter sur la
problématique du déconfinement à la fois
sur le déconfinement pour l'économie
pour préserver l'économie réunionnaise
mais aussi ce qui nous préoccupe au
premier plan c'est la rentrée scolaire
du 18 mai donc on va pouvoir s'exprimer
longuement cet après midi ça va être
difficile parce que c'est surtout le
vous allez voir probablement la
responsabilité des maires qui va être
mise en avant dans ces dans l'hémicycle
aujourd'hui est ce que nous risquons est
ce que nous risquons aussi de subir
nous ne voulons pas avoir de vagues
épidémiques et donc il faudra qu'on soit
très progressif dans le des compliments
et surtout très sérieux pour les
habitants dans le respect des règles aux
barrières
[Musique]
c'est une méthode qu'on met en place
cette méthode c'est le travail en commun
cette méthode c'est comment chacun
ensemble nous sommes capables de relever
les défis parce que si on travaille tout
seul dans la poêle c'est évidemment sur
qu'on ne peut pas réussir il faut unir
nos forces unies à nos moyens après
l'allocution du gouvernement ces élus
ont clairement un rôle central dans
l'avenir de la cité devant le
représentant de l'état la plupart des
maires ont pris la parole
car les problématiques sont nombreux
lyon pour l'étoile les jambes
[Musique]
en vient de se voir des soignants marché
sur la rue de la fère pro 4 étoiles il
vient en france le jeu qu'il est
nécessaire également que nouvel argent
réel
les loups la ligue 1
toutes les questions voir les
inquiétudes sont légitimes dans ce
contexte complètement inédit mais petit
à petit le chemin se tracent le
connaissons maintenant les grandes
lignes de ce déconfinement la réunion a
beaucoup d'atouts d'atouts pour réussir
ce ce déconfinement l'ouverture des
écoles et des collèges pour le
département l'accompagnement social des
personnes de plus en plus fragile
l'impact de la crise sur les recettes
publiques
les questions ne manquent pas et selon
la taille des communes les réponses
doivent être adaptées dans le détail les
sujets se sont d'abord l'action sociale
comment allons-nous dans les temps qui
viennent continu apporté une aide
sociale aux familles même après le
déconfinement donc on va travailler
là-dessus
comment relever le défi de la relance
économique
nous allons travailler là-dessus le
département prendra sa barbe aussi dans
la relance économique
et puis sur le plan de la crise
sanitaire quel apport nous avons
notamment à travers le chu dans cet
environnement séance d'hier tous ces
élus savent qu'il faudra se réinventer
mais une fois encore l'intelligence
collective permettra d'aller plus loin
[Musique]